Now we’re going to look at a very simplistic model
of a food chain. It’s so simple that we’re only going
to consider two species of fish. One is the predator
and one is its prey. You are going to model the
change of either population the predator and the
prey using differential equations in the form of
these equations right here. It’s up to you to figure
out, however, which of these corresponds to the
predator and which one to the prey. There is
several other features of this situation that must be
taken into account. The prey multiplies at a certain
rate. The prey is consumed by the predator that’s
kind of a given. The predators, however, only die
of old age and the predator’s population also
multiplies depending on the amount of prey that is
present. Now in these equations A, B, C, and D
are constants. And in our program over here, you
are going to fill in their values in this dictionary
called base values. We’ve already provided you
with the values corresponding to two keys in base
values. We’ve included the initial amount of prey
and the initial amount of the predator population
measured in tons.
Here however is some other important information
that you’ll need to know in order to do this
problem. The rate of growth of the prey is 0.5 per
year and the life span of the predator is five year.
In addition, we will reach an equilibrium situation
or a steady state situation with the amount of prey
reaches five times and the amount of predator
reaches one times. You are going to use this
information, a little bit of logic and these equations
to calculate A, B, C, and D.
Once you enter A, B, C, and D into base values,
we’ll move down to look at this function called food
chain. Here you’ll use the familiar forward method
to calculate the future populations of the prey and
the predator at each time step. Lastly, you’ll do a
bit of sensitivity analysis. We are going to add in a
degree of uncertainty to this problem to make it a
little bit more complex. Let’s say that A, B, C, and
D as well as the initial amounts of both fish are
uncertain by plus or minus 10%. Similar to your
earlier quiz you are going to create dictionaries for
the minimum and maximum values taking this
uncertainty into account and then determine which
of these six parameters A, B, C, and D and the
two initial values has the largest impact on the
maximum amount of prey. Again, office is very
similar to the quiz insensitivity analysis that you
saw on the unit itself. So if you’re having any
trouble, you might want to review that quiz and of
course you can always come to the forums for
more help. Good luck.